you know I wouldn't normally air my
domestic grievances on the show I don't
believe in you know getting into
personal things and talking about things
that happen at the home with the family
but I have to say that I I got into a
pretty heated argument last night in my
house very emotional with my kids and
because they claimed that goldfish
crackers are better than cheez-its and
so we got into a big debate about it
because it's just an absurd claim
obviously and the thing is they had no
facts they had no evidence they had no
logic they had done no research and they
were just making this claim so I just
demolished them in the debate I
annihilated that Mosin even close and
here's the moral of the story when given
the chance
you always have to own the libs okay
owning the libs is a moral obligation
even when the libs are your own kids
even when the libs are six years old
which my kids are and really all
six-year-old six years six year olds are
libs at the end of the day they you know
operate the same sort of and they argue
the same sort of way also so anyway I I
guess I I thought about maybe spending
the whole show talking about the cheese
at verse goldfish question but I think
I'll save that for another day today I
want to begin with
talking about president Trump being
conclusively and absolutely vindicated
against at least one of the accusations
against him and I think that there's
when we look at this situation there's a
lot we can learn about it so we're gonna
talk about that in just a second but
first I want to tell you that today's
podcast is brought to you by even Shara
watches which I happen to be wearing
right now no matter what you consider
your style to be a classic quality
wristwatch is something that I think
every man needs because there's going to
be occasions where you want to look
classy you want to dress things up a bit
and wearing a computer on your your
wrist wearing an Apple watch just isn't
going to get it done we're partnering
with VIN share oh so you can get a truly
stunning watch at an even more
impressive price exclusive for our
listeners then Cheerios offering a 15%
off deal off of their exceptionally
crafted watches go to vin cheerio
watches dot-com forward slash walsh and
use code walls to save an extra 15% off
that's VI NC ero watches dot-com forward
slash Walsh code walls for 15% off as I
mentioned you know I'm wearing one of
the watches right now if you can see
this is our first time partnering with
the vintage arrow guys and they were
nice enough to send me one and this one
that I'm wearing right right now is the
chrono s Matt gray I've been wearing it
a lot get a lot of compliments people
tell me that when I when I'm wearing
watch right when I run into someone they
say wow you're normally so ugly
something has changed and then I say
it's the watch you know but also how
dare you that hurts my feelings so as I
said it's the chrono West Matt gray that
I've been watching but there are dozens
of watches you could choose from in fact
I went to the website I picked my own
top five so if you go to vin chair
watches comm forward slash waltz you can
see my picks don't forget to again to
use code walls for 15% off and these
watches look they look a lot more
expensive than they really are it's a
great deal
Finch arrow watches comm forward slash
Walsh
alright a former campaign aide for
president Trump Alva Johnson filed a
lawsuit against Trump months ago
alleging that she was the victim of
battery that's how she puts it battery
she says she was forcibly kissed by the
president during the campaign and this
incident has apparently supposedly
traumatized her and haunted her she
can't stop thinking about it in fact
let's but before I we do have footage
now of the alleged battery and you know
and you so you can see it for yourself
before we play that I want to go back a
few months to Alva Johnson's first media
interview which you could probably
already guess was on MSNBC and she
described this traumatic event I want to
play this for you so you can see how she
described it before she knew presumably
this is before she knew that there was
actual video of the thing itself
happening before she knew that here
her describing her the battery here it
is as he passed me I looked at him and I
said no you go and do a good job go kick
ass because I've been away from my
family for a long time and so he stops
he grabs my hand and he starts looking
at me and then as he's looking at me
he's holding my hand he said I'm gonna
do a good job I'm not gonna let you down
I know you've been away from your family
and I appreciate what you're doing he's
holding my hand holding my hand and then
he starts coming towards me
and so he's still holding my hand and
then I just had like a lot of internal
dialog I'm like okay is he gonna hug me
you know like and then he keeps coming
closer and I'm like okay is he gonna
he's gonna hug me I'm like oh my god I
think he's going to kiss me because he
was coming directly for my face I mean
this is what the Bill of the baseball
cap and so he just starts getting closer
and then when I realized that he's going
to kiss my lips I turned my mouth and he
kissed me he caught me right in the
corner of my mouth so keep in mind how
she described that she was grabbed by
the hand he stared at her tried to kiss
her on the lips
she turned desperately away trying to
evade his mouth as it came toward her
and then the kiss landed on the corner
of her mouth she says that's how she
described it he or she is in the same
interview tearing up and getting very
emotional as she continues to recount
the trauma she suffered the Access
Hollywood tape comes out two things
happen the president says I just start
kissing women if I'm attracted to them
you could do anything and grab them by
wherever and then a number of women make
on-the-record accusations about similar
unwanted sexual contact what's going
through your head when you hear that so
when I heard the audio I mean I was like
screaming in my car I'm like oh my god
that's exactly what he did to me like he
literally described exactly what he did
to me my
to grab the pee he I see a woman it's
like a magnet I can't even help and I
just got right in the kiss I don't ask
and so for me it solved the questions
you know you be kind of second-guess and
you so it's solved every question I had
about the intention it solved every
question I had about the amount of
inappropriateness that that it was and I
never went back to work alright now
here's the thing even if the incident
unfolded exactly as she describes I
think it would be quite a stretch to
call it battery even just based on what
she says just if we were to take it at
face value and say well that's exactly
what happened by that description it
sounds like it could be just an awkward
greeting it doesn't really sound like
battery to me but the real problem is
that her description does not match up
at all with what actually happened just
released yesterday here is a video
confirmed by Trump's lawyers and Alba
Johnson's lawyers they both confirm this
is a real video and it appears to
capture the incident in question watch
this
so there you go
that was that was battery she tells us
if if you were in the room that day now
the thing is when she made this claim
and other people who were obviously a
crowded RV they were in a lot of other
people around the other people around
had come out and said I was there I
didn't never saw I never saw anything
like this happen what is she talking
about now you see why they had no memory
because it was a totally innocuous
nothing event it was a greeting between
two people and nothing more
he never grabs her hand at all the event
unfolds over the course of about three
seconds he doesn't try to kiss her lips
he goes right for the cheek
she doesn't like turn away trying to get
away trying to escape his grasp
in fact she appears looks like she kind
of gives him an air kiss on the side of
his face which for all we know is is all
he did for with her we don't actually
know if his lips physically made contact
with her cheek even if that did happen
who cares this again is a normal
interaction normal greeting between two
people the crying the kind of greeting
that happens every day across the world
probably billions of times a day
especially if you happen to travel to
Europe so I mean if this is sexual
assault then the entire continent of
Europe must be immediately arrested
because then I mean this is this is how
people greet each other in fact not just
Europe I mean you go down south south of
the border you go into Central America
South America many in fact many places
across the world this very normal way to
greet people in our country we tend to
be a little bit more reserved with when
it comes to physical sorts of greetings
and I am too now look I I'm not gonna go
kiss somebody on the cheek as a greeting
I don't even like to hug people if they
are named my family but that's just me
that those are my own hang-ups that's
just my own personal preference I I am
hugged by people if you want to say
non-consensual e all the time like when
I would prefer not to go yeah I'm going
for the handshake they go for the hug
that's
awkward that was with me all the time am
I being assaulted am i traumatized by it
no it's just that's it just it's just a
normal human thing maybe it's a brief
moment of being uncomfortable and that's
all and then you you move on with your
life and that's the end of it so this is
so transparently bogus which is why I
wanted to play those clips of Johnson
talking about the quote battery before
she knew that there were video there was
video of it in fact here is um let's
want to play one more clip from the same
MSNBC interview he or she is describing
her emotional state months after the
kiss happened on the cheek here she is
describing what she was like months
after the the incident I immediately
found a lawyer and a couple of days
after Access Hollywood I spoke to a
lawyer who found me to be very credible
they could see how distraught I was I
was down in Florida a state I didn't
live in I was living in campaign housing
that my boyfriend and I went in when my
roommate went to work and got all of our
things made sure everything you know
left the keys on the dining room table
and found alternate housing that we paid
for and and so I found an attorney right
afterwards but he he for business
reasons he didn't move forward with my
case and so at that point you know James
Comey has the breaking news and so I'm
down in Florida crying my eyes out
listening to salons you know and
breaking news is they're reopening the
Hillary Clinton investigation so I
became terrified because it shifted the
momentum and I'm like oh my god he might
actually win this and so I'm thinking
like what am I gonna do like sue the
president you know I became scared
okay distraught crying my eyes out
terrified scared that another point she
says that right after it happened she
called her parents right after it
happened and she became so emotional
describing it that she had to pull over
to the side of the highway
while talking over a kiss on the cheek
she was kissed on the cheek as she
claimed that she was in tears on the
highway to pull over because she was so
overcome with with it so traumatized by
it is there any conceivable way that
this woman is really that fragile is it
is it even possible that there is any
sincerity to what she's describing well
we know that it's not true but as far as
her description of her emotional say I
mean is it possible that like three
months after she was kissed on the cheek
by somebody she's in her house in tears
crying about it
no I think that that that's just not
even possible this is a con it's a fraud
it's a lie apparently and it's important
for us to see how compelling and sincere
she seemed when describing what turned
out to be the most innocuous human
interaction imaginable and this okay
this feminist is why men are now wary
about working with women or even
interacting with women they don't know
especially alone this is why there's a
it's not just that the false accusation
was made the the apparently false
accusation I should say it's not just
that the apparently false accusation was
made it's that she was so convincing
about it
so appeared to be so genuine and sincere
and so for men you see then II think I
mean this this woman seems to be kinda
like a ticking time be if you if you who
knows I mean if you are interacting with
woman you don't know how do you know if
she's just a normal person or if she's
the next album Johnson who's gonna next
thing you know be in tears describing an
incident that never actually took place
there's a candidate for governor and I
think Mississippi Robert foster who's
getting a lot of blowback right now
because of a policy that he's enacted
where he will not be alone with any
woman
is not his wife period he won't let
women cover him you know if it means
that they're riding alone together or
they're alone together in any context
you know so that so female reporters
female staffers it's not that he won't
hire any females but he's not gonna ever
be in a situation where he's alone with
them he's being called sexist for this
of course and it's being framed as
foster not wanting to be around women
because he doesn't trust himself that's
not it you see it's not that he doesn't
trust himself is that he doesn't trust
the other person necessarily he doesn't
trust that the other person will be
honest about their interactions and of
course it because he doesn't know them
so how is he supposed to know Alva
Johnson I'm sure it's a Trump just
seemed like an another ordinary Stafford
perfectly normal person he trusted her
enough to just greet her in a normal way
he had no idea that he she was going to
turn around and try to turn this into
sexual assault but basically so you
never know never know that's the problem
and you can't be trust him you can't
assume especially as a political figure
and this is where we are now as a
society this is where me too has brought
us I mean it's just not reasonable to
claim that men shouldn't be worried
about false accusations we have
apparently yet another example of one
right here in real time that we can see
for ourselves and this is likely the
second false accusation against Trump in
the last month the first one being
probably the accusation from that from
the kooky advice columnist whose story
just made no sense whatsoever at all now
if you're saying that fears about false
accusations are unreasonable you must
either be insisting that false
accusations don't happen which we know
that's not the case or you must be
saying that false accusers aren't going
to be believed anyway because we're all
so good in society is so good at weeding
them out so you don't have to worry
about it
but we know that's not the case either
in fact we know that
according to the last according to a lot
of people women have to be believed
automatically regardless unless they're
accusing Bill Clinton them in which case
we can ignore them but otherwise women
have to be believed that's what we're
we're told so that is a you see how that
could be a frightening thing for men
women have to be believed we know there
are women out there willing to make
stuff up and we also know that there are
women out there who are willing to make
stuff up and can do it in a way that
seems very sincere as meant now that
doesn't mean that there are millions of
women like that it certainly doesn't
mean that most women are like that but
the point is you don't know and here's
the other thing
according to feminists there are tons of
men out there who are infected by toxic
masculinity and who are either rapists
or or potential rapists
I mean they still claim that what is it
one in every four women on a college
campus are raped that's what they tell
us that's this is that is that the
totally made-up infall statistic 25% of
all women on a college campus are raped
according to according to feminism
now that figure again is just completely
false and made-up and obviously crit now
if that was actually true you would be
insane to send your daughter to a
college campus there's a there's a 25%
chance she'll be raped and you're
sending her there you you'd have to be a
horrible person to do that but of course
that's that's not the case feminists
though think it is or say that it is
which means if just on a college campus
alone if 25% of women are raped on a
college campus that means that there are
just a millions of rapists out there I
mean there are so many rapists so if you
feel that way about it then wouldn't you
be in favor of what Robert Foster is
doing and what when men say look I'm
just not gonna be around women because I
don't you know I I don't know if they're
gonna make something up you would think
feminists would say well fine cuz yeah I
mean like millions of you people are
breakfast so this is probably for the
best anyway according to you if you
think there are that many rapists out
there
wouldn't wouldn't you be the one saying
that men and women should never be alone
together or do you not really believe
the things that you say okay let's a
couple other things this is I just wanna
mention this briefly because this is
nice
Mayor Bill DeBlasio who is a very
serious contender for the presidency
says that if he's president he will pay
female athletes equally okay he'll
ensure that equal pay happens for female
athletes that's really good stuff I
think that's great
it reminds me of my plan if I'm elected
president to make all zebras blue that's
just something I'm gonna do also I'm
going to ensure that all diet soda
tastes just as good as regular soda and
the other thing I'm planning on doing
and this is this is really interesting
part of my applied form that I haven't
heard anyone else talk about is my plan
is I'm going to I'm going to capture a
rainbow in a box and then I'm gonna I'm
gonna seal the box and I'm gonna mail it
to your front door and I'm gonna mail
everybody rainbows in boxes and then the
open the box and the rainbow will come
shooting out and there will be a
leprechaun at the other end of it who
will make you pancakes and give you gold
too so those are my plans my plans are
just as feasible
realistic and mature as Bill de Blasio's
plans and really as any of the Democrats
plans I think my plans are just as good
if not better and more likely to
actually happen okay there's an
excellent article in The Wall Street
Journal today written by Madeline Kearns
which profiles a young woman by the name
of Selina Sewell or what a say Sewell
sou le as a Sewell right now so Selina
16 years old and she you know she truly
is an example of courage and female
empowerment turning the sarcasm button
off erm is not sarcasm
this really is an example of courage and
female empowerment a real example
much more so than certain attention
craving female soccer stars here we have
a girl who's very courageous an athlete
she has filed a civil rights complaint
under title 9 over Connecticut's insane
and sexist policy of allowing biological
males to compete against girls in high
school sports selena is a track star at
a school in Connecticut and girls track
and field has been particularly hard hit
by the gender madness that's infecting
the state and the country as a whole to
male athletes and we talked about this
in the past two male athletes have for
the last two years been dominating girls
track and field in the state scooping up
all the medals while the girls who have
worked for years to earn these medals
are deprived they have no chance they
have no shot because they lack the
biological advantages that these males
possess it's just as simple as that and
you know I ran track and field when I
was I ran male track a field you know
where I belonged when I was in high
school and it is you know you only get
four years to to either win all the
medals you can and achieve what you want
to achieve or to impress the college
scouts and be able to go on to college
and do it so it's only four years you
have to do it and imagine you finally
get into high school you're you're
running varsity track and you've been
training for this and you're very good
you're better than almost all the other
girls out there and then two men show up
and take all that no they don't just
take the glory and everything although
they do take that as well but they take
the they take the medals they take the
actual accomplishment itself I mean
think about how horrible that is and
yeah you know now if you're a girl
racing in a you know doing the 800 meter
race and there are two dudes in the race
too and you come in third and the two
dudes come in one and two you know that
you really won okay those two guys are
cheating their medals don't count
you know you really won but technically
on paper you didn't technically on paper
they took the metals so even though you
know it and everyone else knows it it
doesn't really technically count and
that's that's a horrible thing to
sentences from The Wall Street Journal
article I think sum up the situation
says the results speak for themselves
listen to this since Connecticut's
Athletic Conference enacted its liberal
gender identity policy two men have won
fifteen women's state championships
titles that were held by 10 different
Connecticut girls the previous year 15
this is not again this is not just some
you know it's you that's being invented
by conservatives this is actually
happening they took 15 state
championship titles from the girls and
if you caught that these were titles
that were held by 10 different girls in
the past so in the past you'd have
multiple girls winning these various
different events and that's usually how
it goes that that's how it goes in the
men's field - I mean you're you're not
you in the men's field
you're not gonna usually have two guys
taking 15 state championships in two
years because you're not going to be
able to dominate that many events like
either your your middle-distance your
distance you're a sprinter maybe there's
a little bit of crossover but probably
whoever wins the 100 isn't going to win
the 800 that's if you're in where if you
are where you belong and you have real
competition but this just shows what a
gap what a disparity there is where
these guys can waltz in and they can win
events that they've never even raced
before they just walk in their little
training little practice probably ate a
cheeseburger
you know earlier in the day and they
could just with a gonna win the race no
problem it just because they have
advantages they physically they have
things going for them but the girls
don't I have I don't have the the
numbers in front of me right now but
I've gone through this before I've
written about it you can go find what
I've written on it I've gone and looked
to compare that
these two guys the times that they're
winning with against the girls comparing
those times against the boys and what
you find is that the times that give
them first-place finishes
against the girls and state
championships against the girls against
the guys they wouldn't even place they
wouldn't even be on the track we're
talking about okay this time whatever it
is in the 100 meter that's gonna get
your first place against the girls
against the guys that puts you in like
20th place that is how wide this gap is
that these boys if they were where they
belong they wouldn't have any medals
none because they're slow actually by a
boy standard against the girls they have
15 medals this is great
but fortunately Selena Sewell is
standing up she's so far from what I
read the only girl who has put her name
on this complaint publicly but she's
certainly not the only girl who feels
this way I mean I'm sure they all do but
they they they feel that they can't come
out and say it because they're gonna be
attacked they're going to suffer
consequences and it's true they will be
attacked and they will suffer
consequences that's how crazy this is
this is these are opportunities being
stolen from girls and on top of that if
the girls speak up they will be shouted
down and told to shut up so you want
sexism you want misogyny you want
opportunities being taken from women you
you want all you want examples of all
that stuff here it is alright let's move
on to emails Matt Walsh show at
gmail.com Matt Walsh show at gmail.com
this is from Jennifer says hi Matt while
I completely agree with the point you
brought up the other day regarding
schools filling students heads with
liberal nonsense and that homeschooling
is a great alternative I have to break
it to you that every single homeschool
kid I've ever met is incredibly weird or
socially awkward I think homeschooling
would be an absolutely wonderful
to educate my children in the future but
I also want them to be socially normal I
will just have to hope I successfully
raise my children to not believe the
liberal junk they hear at school like my
parents raised me
I'm sure this comment will put me at the
top of your execution list when you come
into power but I am willing to take the
risk
well Jennifer so I don't need to tell
you you already know that enjoy your
your you know final months or years of
earthly existence secondarily I I like
it you know the good thing about this
show is that this is the only show where
the people who email me I can just
casually threaten to kill them and then
move on and it's so it's totally fine
and normal all right but of course when
I it's not really because when I am in
short what I'm dictator it's you know
it's not it's this is not really killing
it's it's this is a legal punishment you
know so it's a different sort of thing
all right as far as home school kids
being weird you know first of all that's
that's not my experience I've been
around a lot of home school families a
lot of home school kids
I've got home school kids my family I go
to a lot of home school conferences that
is just really not my experience at all
now are there some weird home school
kids out there yeah just like there are
weird public school kids there are weird
people of all different sizes stripes
and backgrounds but is there a is there
a larger proportion of quote weird kids
in home school I don't think so at all
it simply is not my experience and I
think normally now you correct me if I'm
wrong normally when people say that it's
just sort of a stereotype that they've
come to believe and maybe they've met a
few home school kids that have helped to
reinforce that stereotype usually when
people say that though they don't really
have experience being around a lot of
home school families what strikes me
about home school kids is that they are
so intensely normal if that makes sense
they are often so just well adjusted and
and mature and able to carry on a
conversation that's what I find with
homeschooled kids and I think maybe
we're so used to kid
being immature and you know unable to
carry on conversations unable to
interact with adults we're so used to
that that when we meet a kid who's
normal well-adjusted to mature shake
your hand look you in the eye have a
common when we meet that which is which
is healthy and normal and good we think
oh that's weird
and maybe it is weird
by in the sense of being abnormal
compared to what we're used to but what
we're used to is not good I will say
that when it comes to social it maybe we
should stop using terms like weird which
is totally subjective when it comes to
social being socially adjusted when it
comes to being you know socially
developed things like that I think
homeschool way-out does Public School in
that regard way out does it and there's
a very clear reason for that because in
public school what does the
socialization process consist of how our
kids socialized in public school they
are socialized by being thrown into an
environment with a bunch of other kids
and they learn about the world they
learn how to act from the other kids and
they start aping their peers acting like
their peers and and that's what the
quote socialization of public school is
in homeschooling you're around your
parents and other adults much more you
spent much more time around your parents
around other adults the class sizes are
much much smaller a lot of one-on-one
time with adults and not just your not
just your parents either I mean you have
homeschooled coops and other things or
families get together and kind of share
the burden
but still it's all you around a lot of
adults and you're learning from other
adults how to socialize how to behave I
think that's going to make you better
adjusted and so the question is would
you rather your child learn how to
behave from imitating adults or from
taking other kids I think that's the
basic question you have to ask yourself
all right this is from Kaylie says I
apologize in advance for the lengthy
question but the other day in your show
you said it would be foolish to say that
we ourselves have cultural blind spots
that could in the future be considered
as bad if not worse as racism sexism etc
what do you think those blind spots may
be when you eventually take your
rightful place as leader you have spoken
about how you would shoot anyone who
dared do something in public as
despicable as licking ice cream and
putting putting it back with dog owners
who let their dogs go to the bathroom
anywhere and everywhere and didn't pick
it up also be included in those executed
Kaylie yes to your last question
absolutely I mean letting your dog I
just I can't even I can barely speak
about that issue it makes me so angry
the idea that you just let your dog
defecate on someone else's property and
then just leave it there you're bringing
a living creature over to someone's
property say I go ahead and leave it a
ticket defecate on their property leave
I mean I find that to be you have to be
a sociopath to do that as term and as
far as the cultural blind spots well it
probably won't shock you the example I'm
going to give but slavery was a blind
spot in human civilization all
throughout the world for thousands of
years it was just something people did
it was an institution it was accepted
and for thousands of years hardly anyone
even questioned it that was a blind spot
pretty big one I think we also have a
pretty big and very similar morally
blind spot and that is with abortion
abortion is our blind spot and it's not
a blind spot for all of us it's not one
for me hopefully it's not one for you
it's not one for pro-lifers we see it
but this is what we're up against where
for us it's so clear that I mean you're
killing a human being that is wrong that
it's such a clear and simple concept to
us and we're trying to explain it one of
the frustrations we have is pro-lifers
is that people who are in that blind
spot they just don't and it's it's it's
an I think a willful thing there are
willfully ignorant they've closed their
eyes to the truth and so you're just
trying to get them to open their eyes
and close that and get rid of that
blinds but look into that dark and
area of their conscience that's what
we're trying to do much like the
abolitionist we're trying to do and I
think we have a similar frustration that
the abolitionists had where it was like
they were looking around how can you
people not see the problem here are you
kidding me
though I really have to explain this to
you this is from Anthony says Matt I am
emailing you to catch up on the
situation here in Mississippi Robert
Foster is catching hell over not
allowing a female reporter to ride alone
with him all over the state to cover his
run for governor he uses the Billy
Graham rule I recommend the CNN
interview he and the reporter did for
guidance on the issue I worked for
Robert Foster for two years and the way
that the mainstream media is treating
him is making me mad because I worked
for him for two years and he doesn't
deserve this treatment he's a
down-to-earth guy respects everybody no
matter who he's talking to his
popularity is now soaring because of his
treatment and he will be he will keep
Mississippi in Republican hands do you
also use the Billy Graham rule the show
is excellent keep it but keep it up yeah
obviously you know I got this email
before we as you heard we just talked
about the Robert foster situation I
agree that the treatment he's getting
the backlash is totally unreasonable and
as I said what's happening with Trump
now with the situation in Alba Johnson
just proves and it's not the only thing
that proves the wisdom of the precaution
that Robert Foster's taking do I use the
Billy Graham rule yeah I mean it's my
wife and I it's not even like some
official policy that we've sat down and
hammered out and we've come up with the
rules and everything and I think for a
lot of people when you talk about the
Billy Graham rule that's you know they
follow the Billy Graham rule in their
marriage I think for most people in that
camp it's the same thing it's like not
like they've got a whole list of rules
or something you know a complicated set
of guidelines it's just a general
understanding that you know there's
you're not going to go on a one-on-one
lunch date with a member of the opposite
sex unless is a family member or
something like that
you're just you're not going to put
yourself in compromising situations when
it comes to interacting with members of
the opposite sex outs
the family then there are just certain
boundaries you put in place now there
are boundaries with all people their
boundaries with members of the same sex
I mean there are you should always have
boundaries with people all different
kinds of boundaries not just not just
sexual boundaries either so there are
always boundaries but depending on who
the person is what your relationship
with them is their sex their you know
their age I mean all differently all
these factors come into play and they're
going to determine what sorts of
boundaries you have and where those
boundaries are that to me just makes a
lot of sense and most of it I'd say in
my own personal case with my marriage
99% of the boundary setting is just
totally it's like you don't even need to
say it it's really obvious we're on the
same page and that's it it's pretty rare
where you come into a situation where
you actually had to sit down and talk
about okay like how are we gonna handle
this or how's this gonna go we don't
usually have to do that it's just it's
really obvious stuff for the most part
and the reasons for those boundaries are
many reasons for the boundaries one
reason is is the reason I think Robert
Foster has and Wahlberg we've been
talking about you do have to worry about
you do have to worry about false
accusations and and you can have an
innocuous conversation innocuous
interaction you don't know how the other
person is gonna take it or how they're
gonna twist it and use it against you
later on these unfortunately are things
we have to think about there is also the
issue I think when you know when this
whole thing came up with Mike Pence a
couple years ago in the the policy they
have in their marriage which again is a
very normal policy that I think a lot of
marriages have even if they don't talk
about it with that I think it's it's not
just the prop the the chance of false
accusation it is also guarding your
heart a little bit not that you don't
trust yourself or that you know or
anything like that it's just it's just
understanding how people are and and so
just guarding yourself a little bit it's
preventing I think a lot of times with
with affairs that happen in the
workplace
probably almost in every case it begins
with you know two people who are having
seemingly normal interactions and they
grow closer and closer and without
noticing it at first and then a certain
point they come up to a threshold and
they cross that threshold and that's
where the affair happens I I would wager
that almost every affair happens that
way
and in that most of the time it's not
like a guy's going to work and saying it
was oh I'm gonna have an affair and I'm
gonna find someone I have an affair with
it's not how it works it just it
gradually begins to happen and it almost
always begins with sort of the emotional
affair first that the people in the
affair might not even fully realize is
happening especially in the beginning
then it graduates into the physical
stuff part of the reason for putting
those boundaries in place is to you know
like I said there's that threshold you
don't even want to come anywhere near
that threshold like you don't even want
to get to a point where you're saying
yourself oh man I got to pull back this
is getting inappropriate I think the
point of the Mike Pence role the Billy
Graham role whatever you want to call it
it's like I'm not even a get to that
point I'm not gonna get it I'm not gonna
get within 50 miles of that point let's
just be safe and what's the downside
really I mean what are you what are you
missing out on you're protecting your
marriage you're protecting yourself
you're protecting your reputation you're
protecting your kids your family there's
no downside that I can see better safe
than sorry
all right I think we'll leave it there
thanks everybody for watching have a
great weekend Godspeed
today on the Ben Shapiro show AO C's
chief of staff admits his global warming
plan is about completely restructuring
in the entire United States economy
he said the quiet part out loud that's
today on the bench Shapiro show